Thank you to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
And if you are one of the first thousand people
to click the link in the description you can
get a two-month free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
There are so, so, so many microbes in the
world.
This far into our journey, it’s kind of
astonishing to think that for all of the exciting
and odd creatures we’ve watched, we’ve
only kinda dipped into the shallows
of the microcosmos.
And like, have you ever sat back and been
overwhelmed by the enormity of this minuscule world?
Of just how many organisms are out there,
both known and unknown, whose lives have been
sustaining ecosystems and changing climates
and doing just so much stuff for eons and
eons as this diverse, invisible mass?
Scientists have been parsing through this
overwhelming world for a few centuries now,
identifying the specifics of how individual
organisms live and connecting them to the
bigger picture of how our world works.
But what we especially love to do with the
natural world is categorize, and perhaps the
most familiar image of the categories we’ve
created is the phylogenetic tree.
The goal of phylogenetic trees is to track
the organisms we know of through their place
in evolution.
Take, for example, these various corkscrew-shaped
bacteria, members of the Spirochaetes phylum.
This phylogenetic tree is from the 90s and
has been updated with more data, but we’ll
use it just for now because it's relatively
simple and that’s useful for explaining
how the trees themselves work.
The ends of these trees are the various spirochetes
that scientists have been able to study, and
if you move to the left, you can see their
branches coming to an unnamed ancestor shared
with other similar spirochetes.
These ancestors then branch back and connect
with each other in various structures, creating
that oh-so-familiar tree-like structure.
And at the bottom is E. Coli, which functions
here as an outgroup, a useful reference as
something not immediately part of the Spirochete
phylum.
We use these diagrams along with the words
“kingdom” and “phylum” to categorize
everything from the tiniest microbe to the
largest whale, but it’s important to remember
that these trees are our interpretation of
what we’ve seen.
Nature didn’t set out to create kingdoms
and phylums, those are categories we created
to help us make sense of the natural world.
It takes a lot of complex work to simplify
nature in this way, and the process behind
creating these evolutionary trees has itself
been an evolving one.
In the days of Darwin, evolution was connected
to the things we could see, and when it comes
to macroscopic animals, the things we see,
like anatomy and fossils, are very useful.
Microbes though, are a bit tougher.
When we first began observing them, we tried
to understand them with words we already knew,
which led to confusion over whether they should
be considered tiny plants or tiny animals.
But with time and more observations, scientists
began to divide these organisms, and really
all of life, into two overarching categories:
bacteria and eukaryotes.
This dichotomy would be most obvious in the
microcosmos, but these divisions were still
just a container that hid a confusing array
of connections.
Bacteria, for example, might be grouped together
according to all sorts of factors, like their
ability to form colonies or the danger they
posed to humans.
But it hadn’t always been clear that the
commonality of these traits necessary links
in anyway to how they evolve.
We’ve seen this again and again in our journey
through the microcosmos: in the amoebas and
euglenoids and so many other organisms whose
evolutionary connections seem straightforward
based on their morphology.
And then, inevitably, we bring out the source
of so many plot twists.
We’re talking about molecular phylogeny
and the host of techniques it encompasses
to reveal genetic connections that our eyes
cannot see.
But molecular phylogeny doesn’t just show
us a whole bunch of things we got wrong.
It’s helped reveal new categories and relationships
within the microcosmos.
The seminal work behind these techniques was
published by Carl Woese and George Fox in
1977, and it was rooted in a straightforward
but powerful notion, that the sequences of
molecules inside microbes could help us make
connections that their morphology could not.
This wasn’t a new idea: scientists had been
linking amino acid sequences between animals.
But the real challenge lay in figuring out
what molecular sequence would actually be
best to accomplish this goal in microbes.
We needed something universal enough to connect
all organisms, but also simple enough to compare
using the sequencing methods available at
the time.
So Woese suggested an organelle that you might
not think of all that often: the ribosome.
Across all living cells, ribosomes are the
protein factory, taking in RNA and translating
it into the molecules that make our bodies
and all life work.
And the ribosome itself has an interesting
structure, made up of both protein and RNA.
Woese and Fox picked out a particular subset
of that ribosomal RNA, compared the sequence
different organisms used to construct that
segment, and then built a phylogenetic tree
out of the similarities and differences in
that sequence.
Their results did more than just create a
tree though, it revealed a whole new subset
of life that lay outside what we had assumed to be the binary divide between bacteria and eukaryotes.
They had uncovered the archaea, a type of
prokaryote that had been assumed, up to that
point, to be a strange type of extremophile
bacteria.
But thanks to archea’s ribosomal RNA and
additional understanding of their morphology,
Woese and Fox realized that they were separate
from bacteria.
An entire new domain of life.
Molecular phylogenetic techniques have gone
on to shift our understanding of microbes,
raising questions and providing insights into
how everything from sex to eating have evolved.
But there are still many other methods of
evolution that may not be captured by these
techniques, including of course endosymbiogenesis
and horizontal gene transfer.
Everybody’s two favorite non-linear methods
of evolution.
Establishing these phylogenetic trees, for
all that it has helped us simplify nature,
also emphasizes just how many complexities
we cannot easily illustrate.
Connecting organisms through their evolutionary
relationships helps us establish a history
of nature and map out the microbial world
as it exists today.
That map will likely never be complete, but
the work that goes into it helps us navigate
through time and space and through invisible
lives, long gone, to see how our world today
is connected to the microcosmos of the past.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
A lot of us are working at home right now,
and for many people, it’s the first time
they’re experiencing the work from home
lifestyle.
One of the biggest struggles with working
from home is making sure you’re still able
to be productive while living, working, and
spending the majority of your time all in
the same place.
Thomas Frank is a YouTuber who knows a lot
about productivity, and over on Skillshare,
he teaches the incredibly helpful “Productivity
Masterclass”.
He’ll walk you through the steps to setting
up your own Productivity System to help you
be better at making to-do lists, organizing
your files both physical and digital, as well
as tackling the dreaded world of your email
inbox.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real projects to
create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
And it makes it easy with short classes that'll
fit into your daily routine.
A Premium Membership will give you unlimited
access, so you can join the classes and communities
that are right for you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month, and if you’re one
of the first 1,000 people to click the link
in the description, you can get a 2 month
free trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Thank you to all of the people here on the
screen.
They are our Patreon patrons and they are
the reason why we are able to make this show.
So, if you like what we do, we are grateful
if you are grateful to us, but even more grateful
if you’ve grateful to our Patrons.
This is the last episode of Season 2 of Journey
to the Microcosmos.
We’re gonna take a couple of weeks off,
but then we will be back on August 10 with
a new episode.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes James, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.